guernica récemment marion maréchal-le
pen un jour alors s'il vous plaît je
n'enlève en rien d'être un jour je serai
présidente in china notre démocratie est
devenue une annus nacra si emmanuel
macron devrait démissionner ou je suis
en couple avec faudel quasi qu'a dit
marion mariage au début votre main vous
l'avez vu trop tôt oui je l'adoré lie
mais en plus elle a bien plus rien à
déclarer que notre démocratie est
devenue une ethnocratie pour que tu pas
comme ça précédemment le bois tu parles
comme ça alors que sa devise c'est vrai
à la libre interwiew magazine valeurs
actuelles qui lui consacre des pages
dans son nouveau numéro
elle a parlé politique bien sûr et
d'après elle la démocratie dans laquelle
on vit ça s'appelle pas vraiment
démocratie sipa pourvoir wibang 2 mois
c'est pas compris japonais et je la
connais pas je suis pas de lyon je pas
envie de la connaître et la nes de
marine le pen donc à donner son avis sur
ce qui était devenu la france et elle
m'a taclé voilà je leur ai demandé bah
voilà marion maréchal-le pen rapport et
par lynch a pas que les politiques se
mêlent aux maths dans les médias etc qui
me connivences et des me dire ici qu'il
vienne me dire la 4me ray le dire ici
regardez marion maréchal-le pen est de
retour dans les médias après un an de
silence suite à son retrait de la vie
politique pourtant la nièce de marine le
pen affiliés rassemblement national ne
semble pas tout à fait avoir accroché
avec l'actualité et la politique
dans une longue interview accordée à
valeurs actuelles elle livre sa vision
de la france est aimé de fortes
critiques sur emmanuel macron pour elle
le pays serait devenu aujourd'hui une
hanouna cratie une référence appuyée aux
différents responsables politiques qui à
l'instar de marlène schiappa ont choisi
balances ton post ces derniers mois pour
s'exprimer à la télévision notre
démocratie est devenue une année
fassi décidément au rassemblement
national le changement semble être
encore une fois quelque chose qui a du
mal à passer et je sais que vous n'aimez
pas les tricheurs
tiens à dire quand même que maximum avec
son petit air fourbe au lieu de prendre
le 3 il savait que le 2 était bon il a
répondu non alors je vais vous dire ça
va être ça devienne poser la question
quelle nuit sur la prochaine
merci jean michel génération maréchal
l'eau sèche d'aujourd'hui d'ailleurs on
ne sait pas ce qu'elle fait et on s'en
fout complètement
mais un jour elle a voulu représenter le
peuple est là le méprise totalement
disant ça veut dire quoi centre aimerait
ça veut dire que ici des gens qui
veulent s'exprimer
à ses yeux n'ont pas de valeur n'ont pas
le droit c'est ridicule grotesque pour
une ex fâche le plus cadeau qu'on l'a
vite
non mais ça bah non l'invité pas le
mérite elle ne vous mérite pas oh non
non mais que maintenant les gens faire
gases le moana ils vont faire du buzz et
là elle a une petite équipe de com ils
sont dix à amon acratie super terme
comme ça ça va être pris ça va faire du
buzz non elle se servira pas de vous
pour faire du buzz je suis d entente moi
c'est une consécration non ce mr merci
oui je pense a dit rachida dati fait
d'avoir mis hanouna cratie je trouve que
c'est que c'est le symbole même de la
réussite de l'émission d'anesthésiant
nouvelle émission dans une nouvelle
émission que le débat se passe
aujourd'hui chez hanouna et c'est un
compliment pour toi si tu matures